retrieval augmented generation is the
most widely adopted method to give
agents access to your knowledge base
essentially making them domain experts
on your documents for Q&A the big
problem is though that Rag by itself is
oftentimes not powerful enough and so
that's why on my channel over the last
month I've been teaching a lot on a
gentic rag which is one of the most
powerful ways to level up rag making it
more powerful and more flexible to work
with the different types of documents
that you have recently I showcased my
n8n agentic rag AI agent template which
you can download for free right now and
is a great starting point for you to
build your own agentic rag system with
no code however on this video an
overwhelming number of you asked for me
to make a local AI version of this agent
I mean it literally felt like over half
the comments on this video were you guys
asking for this like hey Cole this is
cool and all but can you just skip to
the part where you make everything local
and I was secretly hoping for this
because I truly believe that local AI
where you control all of your data and
your llms is the direction we need to
head for generative AI as a whole so
right now I'm introducing you to the
local version of this n8n agentic rag
template I'll walk through the workflow
use cases it covers and show you how to
set up everything that so that you have
your own 100% offline secure and
Powerful rag agent and there are some
quirks with working with local llms and
NN that I'll cover later in this video
to save you a huge headache so
definitely stick around for that so in
the last video on my channel Channel
when I covered the cloud version of this
template I obviously talked a lot about
what a gentic rag is and why it is so
powerful but since then I've come up
with an even better way to explain it to
make it clearer and more concise for you
and that's using this article from we V8
so great resource that I'll have Linked
In the description of this video diving
into what naive rag is or traditional
Rag and then taking a look at how it's
evolved into a gentic rag and so they
have a couple of these diagrams that I
want to go over right here which will
arm us with information to then go into
the na workflow and understand
everything there the first diagram here
is an example of naive or traditional
Rag and we'll see how this levels up
later to a gentic rag so how this works
is you take all of your documents you
split them into chunks so you have
bite-size information to feed into an
llm and then you use an embedding model
to turn all that information into
vectors to store into a vector database
like superbase quadrant or pine cone and
then you take the user's question when
these queries come in and you use the
same embedding model to turn the
question into a vector as well so you
can use some Vector mathematics behind
the scenes to match the question with
the document chunks that have the most
relevant information and then all of
that is combined together into a single
prompt for the llm so you're giving it
something like a system prompt with
instructions the user question and then
the relevant chunks that were received
and then hopefully the response that you
get back from the llm has the answer
because the chunks had the right
information to answer the question now
the problem with all of this is it is
considered a one shot you look up
information in the vector database and
you do it only one time and there's only
ever the opportunity to do it once the
large language model at the bottom here
never has the chance to think to itself
oh I actually want to reward the user's
question or maybe there's a different
Vector database I want to search or
maybe I want to look at the data in a
different way it has no way to reason
about how it explores the knowledge base
and so that is when we want to graduate
to a gentic rag Now we move on to this
diagram where we have an implementation
of a gentic Rag and the tools we see
here don't correspond exactly to what I
have in my n8n workflow but that's just
because there are different ways to
implement a gentic rag and so both this
and my n workflow are good examples and
this still illustrates what I'm trying
to show very clearly and so instead of
there being a retrieval before we reach
the llm with agentic Greg the agent
comes first and then it has tools
available for it to perform Rag and then
also this is a very key thing explore
the knowledge base in other ways and so
in this example it can search through
multiple Vector databases and it can
decide when it wants to look in each one
so we have a lot more reasoning baked
into this whole retrieval process and it
has other tools like web search to look
up information in different ways and
like we'll see in my n8n workflow we can
also look at the knowledge base in
different ways so we aren't just always
doing a retrieval based on Vector
mathematics an endless amount of
possibilities available to us for the
different ways you look at a knowledge
base using the agent to reason about
that instead of there just being some
kind of precursor workflow to to take
information from a vector database and
dump it into the agent and so that is
what agentic rag is as a whole now we
can dive into our workflow armed with
this information and take a look at our
specific implementation so here is the
full local agentic reg n8n template and
you'll notice that this is very similar
to the cloud version that I built
recently on my channel I'm doing that
very intentionally because don't fix
what ain't broken right like if I gave
you a good template as I promised then
when we go to the local version we want
to keep it as similar as possible and
just switch to the local AI services
like olama and a self-hosted super base
and so that's what we're doing right
here and what makes this agentic regag
let me zoom in on the agent tools here
we are giving the agent the ability to
explore the knowledge base in different
ways with all of these tools that we
have to interact with postgress which
this can be vanilla postgress or
self-hosted super base as well for a
local implementation and so let's just
go through some examples right now and
see what this looks like watch it
leverage these different tools to answer
questions that naive rag usually
wouldn't be able to buy itself so for
our testing here the local llm that I'm
using is quen 2.51 14b so a relatively
small model and I have a version with an
8,000 token context limit that'll show
you how to set up later because olama by
default limits you to only 2,000 tokens
which is not enough for systems like
this and so that's one of the big
headaches that'll help you solve later
on but right now let's just go ahead and
test this out so I want to ask it a few
questions to force it to use these
different tools to explore the knowledge
base in different ways based on the
question that we're asking so I have
Claude uh generate all this fake data
for a maritime tech company and so for
the first test I just want to do a basic
rag retrieval so scrolling down here I
just want to ask it who the CEO of this
company is and so I'm expecting it to
use this tool on the right for a simple
rag lookup because there's nothing more
complex it's a very basic question let's
just test it simple at first I'll just
ask who is the CEO of the company and we
can see with the N end workflow as it
decides to use these tools we have the
green box around it so in this case it
didn't decide to use these other tools
that we have for it like listing
documents getting file contents querying
our rows but it did do the rag lookup
and it got us the right answer Dr Alisa
vanderhoven that is the correct answer
now for the second test I want to ask it
a question where rag might work because
I don't have very many documents in this
test environment but it'd be the kind of
question that rag could often get wrong
so going back here I have a brand new
chat end I'm going to ask it uh who was
in the Feb 12th meeting and the reason
I'm asking this is because when you have
a ton of different meeting notes for
different days in a knowledge base a lot
of times rag does not do well because it
pulls the information from the wrong
meeting notes especially if the chunk
for the attendees is far away from the
information that actually says the date
of the meeting and so I'll ask it this
and we'll see then instead of Performing
reg hopefully we'll watch it use one of
these other tools and yes sure enough it
did so it used the tool to list all the
documents available in the knowledge
base and then based on those titles it
picked a couple to read from to take in
that entire document to use to answer
our question and so hopefully what it
picked to read from is yeah it picked to
read the meeting minutes document that
is if I go back here this one right here
so our February 12th meeting and
hopefully it should give us this list of
attendees let's go back and see if we
got the right answer and yes sure enough
we did that is the right answer all
right looking good and yep going back
here that list corresponds exactly now
for my favorite kind of test we're going
to be testing with tabular data because
rag usually does absolutely terribly
with tables like this especially if we
have more than just a test environment
here where we have thousands of Records
in our tables because one rag just pulls
relevant chunks and those chunks might
only be a part of the table so only even
have all of the records available to do
analysis like Computing the average
overall rating for example and also llm
suck at math so by themselves just
looking at the data in a prompt it's not
going to be able to calculate the
average very well and so what I did with
this template this tool right here
actually allows the agent to treat Excel
and CSV files as SQL tables so it can
write SQL queries to do things like
compute the average overall ratings
let's just see that in action right here
this is the kind of thing that rag would
fail horribly with again especially if
my tables were much larger and so I'll
ask it what is the average overall score
based on the customer feedback not
perfect spelling there totally good
doesn't really matter and we'll watch it
use this tool that it hasn't yet because
it's going to execute a SQL query and
once it executes it I'll click into it
so we can see it's not the most trivial
SQL query so it's very impressive that
llms can do this especially smaller ones
like quen 2.51 14b I mean that's the
best part of this whole thing is it's
not even that big of an llm all right
and there we go it executed the query
took a little bit there so I had to
pause and come back but yeah look at
this is the query getting the average
overall rating and the answer is 7.89
and that is the correct answer and it
gave it back to us absolutely perfect
and one thing I really do want to call
out is that your results will be
inconsistent depending on the local
large language model that you use
because as you're using these really
really tiny ones of course the results
are going to be a lot different than if
you're using the cloud version of this
template we're using all of these super
powerful llms like Claude 3.7 Sonet or
gbt 40 but it still is so cool the kind
of power we can have with local Ai and
with this whole setup we are 100% secure
and offline that's the advantage of
local Ai and so now I'm zoomed out here
I want to walk through this entire
workflow for you and show you how to set
it up and I did build this to be a part
of the local AI package that I've been
working working on on my channel and so
I have the Json workflow for this
template for you to download available
here in this repository but I will show
you as we're setting up the credentials
how you can hook up things outside of
the local AI package as well as within
it the sponsor of today's video is cesia
and I am genuinely excited to bring them
to you today CU they're making some big
waves in the voice AI space there is no
denying that AI is completely
revolutionizing both voice content and
products online education customer
service spots audiobooks and even video
games the need right now for natural
sounding and responsive voice Tech is
growing and growing but the big problem
with most voice AI Solutions right now
is they're too slow too unpredictable or
too robotic and caresia is tackling all
of those and they're doing it for voice
agents voice cloning voice changing and
text to speech they are also about to
release Sonic 2.0 their next model that
is a complete GameChanger it's based on
a revolutionary State space model
architecture and it delivers voices that
are unbelievably realistic and even the
previous version of their model was
second place in a bunch of thirdparty
evaluations only trailing behind open Ai
and so who knows Sonic 2.0 might take
the crown now and what makes sonic 2.0
so incredible is both the speed as low
as 40 milliseconds for latency and
unprecedented control to change things
like emotions accents and speed with
remarkable precision and then in the the
cartisia playground you can clone your
own voice with as little as 3 seconds of
your audio it is just unbelievable and
so I'm recording my voice right here
I'll give it about 10 seconds and then
we're going to have something that is
just as good as other platforms like 11
lab it is just amazing so I'm going to
stop it give my voice a name select my
language and then clone it and then
within a few seconds we'll have a voice
that's ready for us to try out which you
could also invoke through an API as well
so I'm going to paste in a sample prompt
just go ahead and listen to this gentic
rag with local AI is an absolute Game
Changer like that definitely sounds like
me I am very impressed and with the two
primary models in their family cesia is
tackling all the major problems that we
have with voice AI right now cuz they
have Sonic Turbo when you want insanely
low latencies and then Sonic 2 when you
want a super controllable and very
accurate and precise model so whether
you are a Creator developer or business
owner looking to leverage voice AI I
would highly recommend checking out
cartesia so I'll have a link in the
description to
cia. you can sign up for a free account
right now to discover how powerful it is
for yourself so the first step for
really setting up any AI agent is
getting your database ready and I make
it really easy to do in this template
and your database it's so important
because it stores your conversation
history and your entire knowledge base
and so zooming in on the red box here I
have a couple of nodes that you can run
to create everything for you and so the
first thing that you have to do is
obviously set up your post grass
credentials which I've shown how to do
this for the local AI package before
that's what I'm using right now so my
host is DB that's how I reference the
superbase database service in my Docker
compos stack and then for the rest of
the information you just get that from
the environment variables that you set
up in the local AI package so we have
our database and user which is postgress
by default you set your password and
then the port for postgress is
5432 and then if you're not using the
local AI package you can still do
everything in this template you just
have to change the host from DB to
whatever your local hosted postgress or
superbase host is and so once you have
your credential set up you can
automatically test it right here it
looks good for me and then we can go on
to executing our first table creation
statement and that is the one to create
our document metadata now I'll go into
superbase quick and show you this the
document metadata table shows the
highlevel information for our documents
this is how the llm is able to use that
tool I'll go over to this right here use
the tool to list the documents that are
available in the knowledge base so it
knows which ones to pull the entire
content from when it wants to do that
instead of reg and then we also have
this schema column here that I'll get
into more later for our table files we
want to tell the llm The Columns that
are available so it knows how to write
those SQL queries to work with the
column specifically for the file like
customer feedback or the sales Pipeline
and so that's what the metad data is for
and then we have our table for document
rows and so instead of cre creating a
separate SQL table for every single
tabular file that we have instead we're
storing it all in the same table and
we're using this row data Json B this is
how no matter the structure of the table
we're able to store all of the records
right here in this column and so for one
file we have these columns like the
notes and the status and the cost and
then going down to another CSV file that
I put in here we have the date vessel ID
vessel name so these files all have
different structures but we can store
them all in document rows like this and
then we query just based on this row
data column when the agent creates those
SQL queries to analyze certain files
like the maintenance records for example
and so that's everything for creating
your tables the other table that we have
is the documents table and this is where
we actually store our embeddings for
regag and the cool thing about the
postgress PG Vector store node this is
our rag node it creates this table for
us automatically so we don't even have
to have a third node here to build this
I will say that the text column that
postgress creates in this table is
different than if you're using the
superbase vector node it uses a Content
column so that's why I have one that's
specifically called documents PG here so
if you've followed my tutorials before
and you've been using the superbase
vector store node just know that you
will have to recreate it because it is
slightly different with postgress but I
wanted to use postgress for this entire
workflow because that way you aren't
limited to superbase I know that
superbase is preferred by most people
but also postgress is a lot more
lightweight so I wanted to cover both
here now before we can run our agent now
that we have our database set up we need
to set up our knowledge base and we do
that with this rag pipeline in the blue
box this is the largest part of the
workflow because what we're doing is
we're taking our local files hence the
local file trigger and adding them into
our superbase or postgress knowledge
base and so I already have this workflow
executed here just so I can show you the
inputs and outputs for all the nodes as
we go through them really quick here and
so we are watching for files that are
added or changed you could add deleted
if you want to as well I'm just keeping
it simple and we're watching in this
folder on our machine specifically and
the reason that I picked this path is
because using the local AI package I
have this shared folder on my machine
mounted onto the n8n container That's
What It Is by default so it's probably
the case for you as well so we have all
of our test data some of which we saw
earlier that is now all in the N8 end
container and you do want to include
these options as well for polling and
files and folders otherwise this trigger
will not work it'll just spin forever
waiting for you to add or edit files and
I have seen on Mac computer specifically
sometimes that issue persists even with
these options selected submit a bug to
NN if you see that I know that is
something that they are working on but
anyway once we have this trigger then we
have an event and path so the path of
the file and then the event is either
going to be change or add as in the file
is created for the first time and then
we're going to Loop right here just in
case we are uploading more than $1
document at the same time so the rest of
this workflow is going to be done for
each file that we have uploaded or
edited within that second of polling for
the local files and so the first thing
that we want to do is set the metadata
here so our file ID which I'm just using
the path since unlike Google Drive we
don't really have a true ID and then for
the file type and title just extracting
those with a little bit of JavaScript
from our path and then the first thing
that I want to do before I even insert
anything into the knowledge base is I
want a clean slate if we have already
added the file to the knowledge base at
some point I want to delete everything
and that's what I'm doing with these two
nodes right here so I'm deleting all the
old document records from the document
PG table where we have our embeddings
for reg and then I am also deleting for
any table files all of the rows here in
the document rows table and the reason I
want to do this is I want to absolutely
guarantee that when I update a file the
knowledge base only only contains the
updated information for that file and
doesn't have anything from an old
version hanging around that would
definitely make the llm hallucinate so
we're taking care of that and by the way
for all of the postgress nodes in the
rag pipeline the credentials are going
to be the exact same ones that you set
up when you did the database setup and
so after that now we can get on to
inserting our document metadata so this
is our first insertion into the
knowledge base where we are adding in
this record just starting with the ID
title and created ad and then the schema
for the the tables will come later and
so at this point we are just setting the
title like you can see right there and
then we move on to reading the file to
disk and so we're bringing this file
into our n8n instance so we can then
extract the text from it and that's what
we're doing in this fancier part of the
workflow right here because based on the
file that we are adding to our knowledge
base we have to extract the content in
different ways you can't read a PDF file
the same way that you read a text file
so we have this switch statement right
here that based on the file type just
looking at the extension from the file
path if it's a PDF we go down one route
if it's a CSV we go down another route
and then if it's a text file we go down
this bottom route like we see in my
current execution and this bottom route
is also the default and so if you have
something like a markdown file it can
also be handled as just a regular text
file so we handle different file types
as well and if you're curious if you go
to open uh and go to a new node here and
click on extract from file there are
different file types that are orted from
n8n so if you want to do something like
HTML or Json you could expand this
template to include those file types as
well because you have all these
different nodes to handle these
different file types and so right here
in this execution just very basic
extract the document text so we take our
file the binary data and we get the text
from it to actually have that in the 8
end workflow for subsequent nodes and so
we take that text and then we just dump
it into our knowledge base we use the PG
Vector store node to take all of the
text split it into chunks and then put
it in our knowledge base in the
documents PG table right here and so for
this we have to hook in a couple of
things we have our AMA embedding model
which I'm just using namic embed text
that's the model that comes with the
local AI package by default and then for
the document loader here just using the
default data loader super simple the one
thing that I did add on to this though
is I am adding metadata for this record
including the file ID and file title and
so these pieces information are
available to us in the metadata jsonb
and this is really important because
when we do a rag lookup when this record
is returned the metadata is included so
the llm can actually use this
information to cite its source like it
can tell you that I got this information
from the company overview text document
so that's why we care about metadata and
then finally for the text splitter here
to take our document and turn it into
individual chunks we're just using a
basic recommended recursive character
text splitter with a chunk size of 400 I
got this as a recommendation in my last
video specifically to use 400 so that is
everything for a basic text document
then for our CSV and Excel files we do
something a little bit extra here
because we have to insert the rows into
the document rows table as well so first
we extract from the Excel and CSV just
like we would do with our text and PDF
documents but we do two things in
parallel first we insert the table rows
so with a little bit of fan JavaScript
here I take all of the data for each row
and I insert them right here into the
document rows so we have this Json B
that has all of the column data for each
row and then also what we want to do is
add it into our knowledge base for
regular rag cuz sometimes a rag lookup
does actually work well with tables
especially if you want to look up a
specific row so even though we are
primarily going to be using the rows to
write SQL queries for our tabular data
we still also want to add it in to the
knowledge base just like our other more
text based files and so we aggregate all
of the rows together then we summarize
it so that we have the text
representation of the entire table and
then just like with the text document we
insert it all into postgress or
superbase with the chunks and everything
like that and then the final thing that
we do is we set the schema as well and
so this is within the documents metadata
table we create the schema just
extracting all of the columns from this
file and then we update that record so
we go back to document metadata remember
earlier on in the workflow we already
created this record it just didn't have
the schema yet so now this is where we
add in the schema so we say for customer
feedback here are the columns available
so you know how to write a SQL query to
query this row data right here and that
is it that is our rag Pipeline and so
now you can literally just go and dump a
bunch of files in this folder that's
being watched and you can go into the
executions Tab and watch it load each of
these files individually into the
knowledge base and it happens happens
very very quick even with not a super
powerful machine the namic Ed text model
from Alama is super fast this trigger
it'll instantly trigger unlike the
Google Drive one where you have to pull
every minute so within just like a few
seconds you'll have a bunch of files
already ready in your knowledge base
ready to now chat with the agent and get
it set up last but not least we get to
set up our AI agent that's everything in
the yellow and green boxes here and so
first of all two triggers for this we
have a chat trigger that's what gives us
the ability to interact with it right in
the n8n UI and then we also have a web
hook so we can use our agent as an API
endpoint and then I have this edit
Fields right here just to standardize
the input that comes from both of these
triggers and then we get into our tools
agent and I have a very basic system
prompt here just telling it that it's a
personal assistant who has these
different tools for a gentic rig to look
at the knowledge base in different ways
and I give it some instructions on when
to use the different tools as well and
then for our chat memory here just very
basic postgress chat memory same
credentials you already set up and then
it'll automatically create this n8n chat
histories table just like it
automatically creates the documents PG
table for our embeddings and then for
our chat model this looks a little weird
here like why is there an open AI icon
when it's all local AI don't worry this
is using olama it's just within my open
AI credentials I set the API key to
whatever the heck I want it's olama it
doesn't matter and then I change the
base URL to point to my Lama container
with the local AI package and then if
you are using AMA host on your machine
you would just change this to Local Host
now the reason I have to do this the
reason I can't just use the chat olama
model node it's a weird glitch in NN
where if you use this guy which I wish I
could instead of the open AI one if you
use this one you'll get an error
whenever it invokes the rag tool and
I've seen this on the community forums
already it's something like expected
string but received object or some kind
of erid like that you'll get that when
you use this guy so we can't use this
for now and it's kind of unfortunate
I'll expand on this more later so we
just have to use the open AI one and
then we can change the base URL and then
it still will be able to dynamically
load the models that we have pulled in
olama so it still works pretty well and
then for our tools here first we have
reg just with our postgress PG Vector so
just a very basic description for the
agent to know when to use this tool you
could probably expand this prompt just
just like you could with really any of
the prompts in this template it's just
to get you started um but yeah then we
have our table name documents PG
limiting to four and then we're
including the metadata as well things
like the title and the file ID that I
showed earlier so that the llm can cite
its sources when it uses this rag tool
and then for the embeddings just using
AMA just like we saw in the rag pipeline
same exact model and the credentials for
this again you just reference the olama
service if you are in the local AI
package or you change this to Local Host
if you you are using oama on your own
machine and not within a container with
the local AI package and then we have
our last three tools here we have one to
list our documents again going to the
documents metadata table and so that
just is a simple list over this table
not much more than that and then the
tool to get the contents of a specific
file as well so we have this kind of
fancy query here basically just going to
the documents PG table that na creates
for us taking all of the chunks for a
single document and combining it
together to get the full text for that
document and then we have it
parameterized here so the llm decides
the file ID and then everything else is
predefined in the SQL query here and
then it's actually kind of different
than the last tool here because for the
querying the tabular data we allow the
llm to completely generate the SQL query
and this is where we might get a little
bit more inconsistent results cuz we're
requiring it to generate a whole query
and sometimes smaller llms in particular
can hallucinate bad queries but in the
description for the tool here I give it
some examples and I found that this
helps a lot so the description of the
tool this is given as a part of the
prompt to the llm so we tell it how to
use this tool when to use it and some
examples of good queries taking
advantage of this row data column so
basically allowing it to understand how
we have things structured in this
document rows table so it can write good
queries to reference all of this Json B
properly and so that is everything for
our tools the very last thing that I
want to cover is that huge headache that
I promis to save you cuz here's the
thing olama models by default they only
have a context length of 2,000 tokens
and so what that means is as your
prompts get longer as you include more
information from your rag lookups you
start to lose things like the system
prompt and the tools instructions
because all that stuff at the start of
your prompt gets overridden by the
things that are in the most recent part
of the context window because that
length is only 2,000 tokens and trust me
you will go over 2,000 tokens for most
use cases with AI agents and so looking
at the chat AMA model node we do have
the option here to change the context
length right here in NN so yeah here's
the default 248 we can change this to
8,000 or whatever but as we saw earlier
we don't have the luxury to use the AMA
chat model because of that glitch with
Rag and so we have to use open Ai and
just change the base you
but it doesn't have an option here to
change the context length like we have
in ama maximum number of tokens that
defines the max for the output that
doesn't change the context links that
doesn't work I did actually test that
and so the solution here if you look at
the models that I have for AMA I have
the ones that I installed directly from
olama and then I have these versions
that I created that have 8,000 context
as that parameter set for the model and
so I'll show you how to do that right
here so in the local AI package AG you
can have your olama container up
otherwise if you're running AMA locally
you can just do this in the command line
but what you want to do is create this
thing called a model file and so I'm
going to run this Command right here
you're going to want to change the model
ID or the context link just based on
whatever you want to do for your use
case and I'll show you the contents of
this because essentially what we're
doing is we're inheriting from the base
model and then just changing the context
link with this parameter right here and
then the last command there's just two
commands here and actually I have this
as a comment in the docker compost file
for the local AI package you can see
copy those commands right there the last
command is to create a version of the
model you can name this whatever you
want just based on the file model file
in the current directory and so I'm not
going to run this right here because I
already have well I guess I did run it
anyway it just recreated the model for
me so now we have a version you can see
that happened instantaneously because it
doesn't have to redownload the model
it'll use what you already have
downloaded and then just make a new
version that has that extra context
length and so you can do an olama list
and you'll see it just with all of your
other models and so now we have a
version of AMA that has an extra context
link and that's what makes it not
hallucinate completely when you actually
start to get some of these tool
invocations more data coming in from
your knowledge base the context length
is important it'll definitely go to Five
6 7,000 tokens as you're looking out
your documents so that is everything for
the local version of the n8n agentic rag
template and just for fun let's give it
another spin here so I'll just ask it
another random question like what are
areas for improvement something very
general that we might actually wanted to
look at multiple documents to get a good
answer for us let's see what it does I'm
actually super curious I've never asked
it this question in particular um but
yeah as this thing spins I just want to
say that if you have any questions at
all with this template as you're going
over it as you're extending it to fit to
your use case just let me know in the
comments I always love to chat with you
share ideas with you and just see what
you're building as well and yeah look at
this based on the information available
Geographic expansion product
enhancements yeah looks pretty cool this
agent is just fantastic and a lot of
things I want to do in the future as
well to continue to expand it it is just
crazy to me the kind of power we have
these days for local Ai and no code and
I hope that this n8n agentic rag agent
can be a good example of that for you so
please just take this template and run
with it to build out your specific use
cases and I would love to hear what you
make as well also a lot more content
coming out soon for local Ai and a local
AI package so stay tuned for that if you
appreciated this content and you're
looking forward to more things local AI
I would really appreciate a like and a
subscribe and with that I will see you
in the next video